benvenuti a grande fratello mantenuto il
par minuti ciao ciao tiziano cristiano
malgioglio
ciao simona simona izzo nov ancora un
ciao ciao
allora sta per accadere qualunque cosa
fidatevi di me ebbene sì perché
finalmente questa sera entrerà nella
casa del grande fratello arida ma chi se
ne frega con tutte le belle donne che
abbiamo in italia ma che ce ne frega
della spagnola no cristiano allora non
ricominciamo a tutti lavorano tutti
parlano di le regole problema rimane il
problema è la spagna ce l'ha mandata a
noi ma noi non la vogliamo noi ce ne
mettiamo niente ma cristiano come so e
magari te un amore ma che non la conosce
nessuno ma chi è che ronzon ma non è
vero che non la conosce nessuno
tutta la spagna parla di lei ma scusa ma
con tante belle donne decidono in italia
ma chi se ne frega
allora visto che ieri notte mi hai
mandato un messaggino alle 4 del mattino
bling long mi hai fatto svegliare melai
promesso che ti sta rispettivi ingrate
nato è vero certo certo engadina de min
allena denis pure castigatore engadina
temi dalle animi moore e non troppo
stretta per pavone malta incatenate lo
incatenate lo facciamo la entrare aida
barbara buonasera a tutti ci sono cinque
modi d oro per adorare la tua vita in
modo e stoico tutto questo lo sa e
scoprire i candidati dai facendo cosa
sta facendo
non capisco i da sono pronta volentieri
per entrare nella cassa e farvi godere
tutti siete pronti
ma perché lo chiami dovuto aida judo
lo chiami tu tu me che l'ho e mi sembra
il cagnolino che questi anni con mio no
vabbè me ne vado ciao arrivederci
barbara bovio baciarti bobbio
abbracciarti ma che ce ne frega della
spagnola
basta cristiano devo farla entrare aida
entra nella casa dopo ciao
passiamo momento pochino piccante perché
perché tra le mie mani come potete
vedere o la busta sala gialla gialla
gialla all'interno della quale c'è
l'intera conversazione a sfondo sessuale
tra simone coscia fidanzato
ufficialmente da quattro anni con
l'onorevole stefania pezzopane e la
nostra lucia bramieri grande fratello
fabio entrare dentro la casa così
chiedo ai due concorrenti delle
spiegazioni su questi messaggi ragazzi
eccoci si barbara allora per favore in
confessionale lucia bramieri e simone
cozza avranno già capito allora ragazzi
detto questa busta o i famosi messaggi
hot che a quanto pare vi sareste
scambiati qualche mese fa allora simone
coccia all'una e venti di notte scrive a
lucia bramieri dove ti piace mordere o
no scusa hai scritto dove ti piace
mordere e certo matta ma in che senso
quando ti piace mozzica perché a me
all'una e mezza a me viene pure fame
quindi devo mordere
mangia a non era una cosa a sfondo
erotico oppure no mela un panino per
forza su fisico ah ok ma chissà cosa ne
pensa colei che ha ricevuto questo
messaggio al 120 di notte lucia lucia
bramieri
quando ho ricevuto quei messaggi o detto
bo questo qua è fuori barbara io neanche
mi ricordo e tra l'altro non le mando a
dire come stai e io ho appena ricevuto
detto questo è fidanzato e per me era
chiusa lì nel senso è una schietta
ebbene sì siamo giunti alla fine di
questa fantastica puntata e infatti mi
state ri nei commenti si è rifugiato il
video e se volete la terza puntata del
grande fratello 15 e ricordatevi sempre
che se il video vi è piaciuto dovete
iscrivervi al canale e ricordatevi
sempre di seguirmi su tutti gli altri
social facebook
instagram e musicali ma soprattutto
ricordatevi sempre che tu poni figli nel
mio cuore ci siete voi
adoro col cuore aspettate aspettate un
attimo
vi faccio vedere in anteprima
internazionale
la nuova sigla del grande fratello 15
siate pronti musica
[Musica]
[Applauso]
benvenuti a grande sensata danno
d'organo insopportabile nota non credo
di poter giocare
sono una donna era urgente escuso
engadina anni sono stati definiti cosa
una terra e tu ti sei mai venuti a mani
nude ben aiuti a benvenuti ad un'estesa
teaterno barbaro idropotabile no ma non
credo di poter giovare sono una donna e
travolgente escluso immaginarmi lavoro
sul my story da quanti cos'è una terra e
dovi 6 batte bene